Croesus - All the Money in the World
Can money truly bring happiness?
Well, if you ask King Croesus, then the answer
is a resounding “yes.”
He ruled over the kingdom of Lydia at a time
when it was one of the wealthiest and most
powerful kingdoms on the planet.
He amassed untold riches the likes of which
the world had never seen.
He spurred on the world economy by issuing
the first gold coins.
And yet...it all came crashing down in the
end.
Ever fickle, fortune abandoned Croesus and
he witnessed his once-mighty kingdom crumble
to dust and become just a small part of an
even bigger, more powerful empire.
And, if oracles are to be believed, this had
all been part of a prophecy over 100 years
in the making as Croesus had been destined
to pay for the sins of his ancestors.
The Kingdom of Lydia
The early years of Croesus will forever remain
shrouded in mystery.
As with many other ancient historical figures,
one of our main sources will, again, be Herodotus
who actually focused the beginning of his
very first book in his Histories on Croesus,
but even Herodotus did not have much to say
about the Lydian before he became king.
And, as is always the case with these ancient
texts, there is going to be some legend mixed
in with the truth, so have your pinch of salt
at the ready.
Croesus was born circa 595 BC and would go
on to rule over Lydia, a kingdom located in
Asia Minor, or Anatolia, as we know it today.
The kingdom itself is an enigma, as no literature
or monuments with extensive inscriptions have
survived.
What we do know of the Lydians comes to us
second-hand from the Greeks.
The name is derived from Lydus, an early king
of Lydia who ruled sometime during the 2nd
millenium BC.
He was part of the first of three dynasties
that ruled over the kingdom - the Maeoniae.
How many there were, how long they ruled,
how they lost power - we have no idea, but
at one point they were replaced by the Heraclid
Dynasty, so called because they claimed to
be descendants of Hercules.
About them we have a little more information
thanks again to good, ol’ reliable Herodotus.
He said that the Heraclids ruled over Lydia
for 22 generations, or 505 years, with a son
succeeding his father each time.
We only know the names of three of them, but
relevant to us was only the last King Candaules,
also known as Myrsilus to the Greeks.
The story of how he lost power is a fascinating
one that merits repeating, even if it might
be just a legend.
After all, it is not every day that a powerful
dynasty is brought down by voyeurism.
Candaules had a beautiful wife named Nyssia
and she wasn’t just beautiful, she was apparently
one of the most stunning creatures to ever
walk the earth.
At least, that was what Candaules thought.
At first, you might think this was rather
sweet, a man so deeply enamored with his wife.
But the king raved about Nyssia’s beauty
to anyone and everyone who would listen, particularly
his bodyguard and most trusted servant, Gyges.
One day, the king was going on and on about
his wife to Gyges and, looking at his bodyguard,
he detected a whiff of skepticism.
Because, as Candaules thought, a man trusts
his eyes more than his ears, the king decided
that Gyges must see Nyssia naked so that he
may be convinced that she was, indeed, the
most beautiful woman in the world.
Gyges was shocked when he heard and pleaded
with the king but, at the end of the day,
Candaules was his master so, if he wished
it, it had to be done.
That night, the king took his bodyguard into
the royal chambers and had him hide behind
a door.
Nyssia came in, took off her clothes and got
in bed with her husband.
Gyges witnessed the whole thing and then tried
to sneak out, but the queen saw him and instantly
realized what had happened.
Nyssia felt deeply ashamed and decided that
she needed vengeance.
The next day, she called Gyges to her, and
he came voluntarily because he had not realized
yet that he had been spotted the night before.
Nyssia gave him a choice: either kill himself
or kill his master, become king and take her
as his new wife.
So his options were to die or to become rich
and powerful and marry one of the most beautiful
women in the world.
It was a hard decision but, in the end, Gyges
went with option B.
The queen brought him into her sleeping chambers
just like the king did the night before.
The bodyguard waited for his master to fall
asleep and stabbed him with a dagger.
Gyges took over the throne and founded the
Mermnad Dynasty.
It should be noted that this is just one of
multiple stories of how the Heraclids fell.
In another version by Plato, Gyges was a shepherd
who took power with the help of a magic ring
that made him invisible, but that one is a
little bit unlikelier.
Some modern historians adopt a more practical
viewpoint and believe that Candaules was simply
assassinated because he had become unpopular
with the people.
Unsurprisingly, not everyone was happy with
the slaying of Candaules and his death prompted
a minor civil war.
However, Nyssia managed to quell the uprising
pretty fast by decreeing that they should
all heed the decision of the oracle of Delphi.
If the seer ordained Gyges to be the new king
of the Lydians, then he would assume power.
If not, then it went back to the Heraclids.
The oracle sided with Gyges, but divined that
the Heraclids would have their vengeance after
five generations.
The Mermnadae ruled Lydia with great success
for 140 years.
During the reign of the fourth king, Alyattes,
the kingdom covered most of western Asia Minor.
But in 560 BC Alyattes died and he was succeeded
by his son, the fifth generation Mermnad,
Croesus.
King Croesus
Alyattes was a very powerful and successful
king who ruled for almost 60 years.
During that time, he waged many wars to increase
the reach of his kingdom, particularly against
the Ionian and Aeolian Greek city-states in
Asia Minor.
To the east of the kingdom was the Median
Empire who also fought against the Lydians.
However, in 585 BC, while the two kingdoms
were warring, there was a solar eclipse today
known as the Eclipse of Thales.
Both sides took it as an omen and declared
a truce soon after.
After a treaty was signed, the Halys River
became the official border between the two
empires and the two kingdoms even arranged
a royal marriage to help solidify this new
peace.
The Lydian princess offered for marriage was
Croesus’s older sister, Aryenis, who married
the King of Media, Astyages.
Croesus did not know it yet, but this new
relation would later force him into a war
that would bring on his doom.
Croesus’s rise to the throne was not without
incident.
He had clearly been positioned as his father’s
heir when he was given the governorship of
an important city called Adramyttium.
This post was traditionally assigned to the
successor so that he may receive some administrative
experience before assuming the mantle of king.
However, when Alyattes died and Lydia was
getting ready to accept Croesus as its new
king, his authority was challenged by a half-brother
named Pantaleon.
At one point, Croesus was even the target
of a conspiracy and barely escaped being poisoned
by his stepmother.
We do not know the details of this sibling
rivalry but, obviously, in the end, Croesus
prevailed and assumed kingship of Lydia when
he was 35 years old.
As soon as he was certain in his role, King
Croesus resumed the favorite habit of his
father, which was to fight his neighbors.
His first target was Ephesus, a Greek city
on the Ionian coast, located a couple of miles
from where the modern Turkish city of Selçuk
is today.
The city’s main claim to fame was its temple
dedicated to the goddess Artemis which had
been destroyed by a flood sometime during
the 7th century BC.
Croesus conquered Ephesus around 560 BC and
he sponsored, at least partially, the rebuilding
of the Temple of Artemis, making it bigger
and more opulent than before.
It was described as being over 330 feet long,
having 40-ft tall columns, and being made
mostly of marble.
This, of course, would go on to be known as
one of the Seven Wonders of the World but,
by the time such lists started making the
rounds in the Greek world, the temple had
actually been destroyed and rebuilt once more.
Around the mid 4th century BC, a man named
Herostratus set it on fire.
The arsonist was obsessed with fame and wanted
people to know his name at all costs.
What better way than to destroy one of the
most beautiful things in the world?
The Ephesians caught, tortured and executed
Herostratus, but also sentenced him to damnatio
memoriae, the “condemnation of memory”
where he was stricken from every official
record so that his name may be forgotten by
history.
After all, what better punishment could there
be for someone who wanted to be remembered
at all costs?
Unfortunately for the Ephesians, their plan
did not work as a Greek historian named Theopompus
recorded the event and today we still remember
the name and actions of Herostratus.
Back to Croesus, once Ephesus was conquered,
he simply moved on from one target to the
next.
He didn’t rest until all the Greek cities
on mainland Asia Minor were either part of
his kingdom or paid him tribute.
So it happened that Croesus subjected all
the people west of the Halys River except
for the Cilicians and Lycians.
Afterwards, he shifted his focus to the nearby
islands in the Aegean Sea and intended to
conquer them, as well.
In the end, though, he decided against it.
The Lydian army was famed for its horseback
soldiers who, of course, would be completely
useless in naval warfare.
Instead, Croesus made friends with the Greek
island nations.
Toss a Coin to Your King
Unsurprisingly, all
his
conquests made Croesus a very rich man.
In fact, he was probably among the richest
men in history.
Besides the tributes he received from the
Greek cities, the king’s vast wealth also
came from abundant mineral deposits located
throughout Lydia, particularly in Sardis,
the kingdom’s capital.
The expression “as rich as Croesus” is
still in use today, thousands of years after
he died.
His massive wealth aside, Croesus had another
claim to fame which ensured his role in the
history of economics - the introduction of
coins.
The Lydian king is credited with issuing the
first ever gold and silver coins.
These had a standardized purity and a fixed
exchange rate between various denominations
and between the gold and silver variants.
These coins were called kroiseioi stateres
in ancient documents, although today we simply
refer to them as Croeseids.
They depicted a lion and a bull.
The use of coins, period, is generally ascribed
to Lydia, although about a hundred years or
so before the introduction of Croeseids.
This claim is a bit more controversial, though,
as some historical texts say that other places
were first, although still in the same region.
Some ancient writers claimed the city of Argos
used coins first, or the Greek island of Aegina
which had the silver stater depicting a turtle.
If the Lydians were not first, they were definitely
among the earliest adopters.
Their original coins, just like the Greek
staters, were made out of electrum - an alloy
of gold and silver that occurs naturally.
These coins were definitely in use during
the reign of Alyattes, but they were not practical
enough for day-to-day spending.
Even the smallest denominations were still
too valuable to be used to buy something trivial
like a loaf of bread, for example.
This changed during Croesus’s time.
According to Herodotus, again, he was not
only the first to introduce gold and silver
coins, but also the first to use them to sell
goods by retail.
While the original Lydian coins weighed above
10 grams, Croesus issued a wide range of small
denominations, going all the way to 1/48th
of a gram.
This made it possible for Lydians to use coins
in their daily shopping trips.
And in case you were wondering how the Lydians
determined the purity of a coin, they used
a tool called a touchstone.
It was simply a piece of dark stone made out
of slate, or fieldstone, or other rocks with
a finely grained surface on which soft metals
left a trace.
They took a coin with an unknown gold purity
and rubbed it against the touchstone so it
left a streak.
They then compared the streak to others made
with coins of known purity and simply looked
for a color match.
The fact that Croesus was a conquering warlord
only served to expedite the spread of coins.
They were used in all the Greek cities he
subjected.
From the Greeks, it spread to the Romans who
spread it to the whole of Europe.
When Lydia was conquered by the Persians,
it spread to Mesopotamia.
When the Persians were conquered by Alexander
the Great, he spread it even further and so
it went until coin usage became a standard
across the globe.
A Visitor from Greece
Croesus seemed to live by the creed of “if
you got it, then flaunt it.”
After all, what was the point of being the
richest man in the world if he couldn’t
show off his vast wealth?
He received many esteemed guests, particularly
from the Greek world (that is, the part of
the Greek world that he hadn’t conquered).
Aesop, the fabled fable writer was among his
visitors, but the most notable guest to Lydia
was Solon, the Athenian statesman who reformed
the city’s laws and set the foundations
for Athenian democracy.
After he finished his administrative duties,
Solon left Athens and went on a 10-year trip
to see the world.
Towards the end, he arrived in Sardis where
he was graciously greeted by King Croesus
who rolled out the welcome wagon.
Solon was given a tour of the palace where
he saw all the gold, the silver, the precious
stones, and other vast riches that Croesus
possessed.
Afterwards, the confident king asked his wise
visitor whom he considered to be “blessed
beyond all men.”
The answer probably surprised and even annoyed
the Lydian king.
Surely, he was expecting Solon to say that
“Croesus was blessed beyond all others”,
but he didn’t.
The philosopher concluded that a man named
Tellus of Athens had that honor.
He reasoned that Tellus had a good family
full of noble sons and healthy grandchildren,
and, in his old age, he enjoyed a glorious
death in battle, securing a victory for the
Athenians against their neighbors at Eleusis.
Okay, so Croesus wasn’t first, but surely
he would claim second place, right?
Well, not according to Solon who believed
that runners-up were two brothers from Argos
named Cleobis and Biton.
These two had a mother named Cydippe who was
a priestess of Hera.
One day, she needed to get into town for a
festival dedicated to the goddess, but could
not find the oxen to pull her cart.
Instead, her loyal sons yolked themselves
and pulled the cart for six miles into Argos.
When they arrived in the city, the Argives
gave the brothers a hero’s welcome for their
dedication to their mother and to Hera.
Cleobis and Biton then made sacrifices to
the gods, ate plentifully and fell asleep
in the temple.
Cydippe prayed to Hera that her sons may receive
the greatest boon for the honor they showed
and the goddess agreed.
Cleobis and Biton died peacefully in their
sleep and were allowed to rest for eternity.
In the end, Solon reasoned that he could not
count Croesus among the truly blessed until
he knew that the king died well.
Unsurprisingly, this angered Croesus who sent
Solon away without any lavish gifts, concluding
that the old man was a fool for ignoring his
wealth.
Basically, there were two lessons to take
from Solon’s stories.
One - that money wasn’t everything; and
two - that fortune can be fickle and change
suddenly.
Croesus, of course, immediately dismissed
both lessons, but he would eventually learn
them the hard way.
Soon after Solon departed Sardis, Croesus
had a dream which showed that his son, Atys,
would be killed by an iron spear.
Atys was the heir to the Lydian Kingdom.
Croesus had another son, but he was deaf and
dumb and Herodotus didn’t even bother naming
him.
Fearing this vision, the king forbade Atys
from leading any Lydian armies into battle.
One day, he received a plea for help from
the province of Mysia which was being attacked
by a giant boar that destroyed the fields
and killed the livestock.
Croesus allowed Atys to lead an expedition
to slay the beast.
After all, it was unlikely that the boar would
wield a spear.
Part of that expedition was a man named Adrastus,
a former prince from Phrygia who had been
banished by the king after he accidentally
spilled the blood of his brother.
As Phrygia was subjected to Lydia, King Croesus
took Adrastus in and purified him of his blood
crime.
In exchange, he tasked Adrastus to act as
Atys’s bodyguard and make sure that no harm
came to him.
He agreed, but ended up doing the exact opposite.
During the fight with the boar, Adrastus threw
a spear that missed the animal but hit and
killed Atys.
The king cried and mourned his son, lamenting
that his mighty kingdom no longer had an heir.
However, soon enough, he would have bigger
problems to face as Cyrus the Great was on
the warpath.
Croesus Fights Cyrus
You might recall we said earlier that Lydia
had an alliance by marriage with the Median
Empire to the east.
Well, in 550 BC, the Median Empire didn’t
exist anymore.
It had been conquered by Cyrus the Great and
added to his Achaemenid Empire.
Just like Croesus and many other warlords
before him, Cyrus had a lust for power and
wanted to grow his empire.
He subjugated all the lands in his path and
it was clear to everyone that he was on a
collision course with the Lydian Kingdom as
one of the only other major powers in the
region.
Plus, as the Median queen was Croesus’s
sister, he could not leave this provocation
unanswered.
By the way, if you would like more detail
on the events, we already did a full video
on Cyrus the Great so you can check the link
and learn all about the man who became King
of the Four Corners of the World.
Croesus didn’t want to act rash so, before
he took any course of action, he wanted to
consult the oracles.
However, the question was which oracle should
he trust?
As a test, he sent agents to all the oracles
in the land.
They all left the same day and were to inquire
what King Croesus would be doing 100 days
later.
Out of them all, only two gave answers that
satisfied the king - the oracle of Amphiaraus
and the oracle of Delphi.
The latter was the same oracle that ordained
Gyges to rule Lydia and also predicted the
fall of his dynasty after five generations.
We don’t know what the Amphiaraus oracle
said, but the Delphian seer who was called
the Pythia correctly predicted that on the
hundredth day, King Croesus would eat tortoise
and lamb meat boiled in a bronze cauldron.
After this prediction came to pass, Croesus
made lavish offerings to the temple at Delphi.
He wanted to know if he should attack Cyrus
and the Pythia gave him, perhaps, the most
notorious divination in history.
She predicted that, if Croesus attacked Cyrus,
he would destroy a great empire.
Immediately, he assumed this could only mean
the Persian Empire so Lydia went to war.
As Croesus would later discover, the oracle
was talking about his own.
The prophetess also gave the king some practical
advice and told him to seek out the mightiest
of Greeks and make them his friends.
That would be Sparta.
In the end, Lydia allied with the Spartans,
but also with the Egyptians and the Babylonians.
How Croesus got each one to join his war against
Cyrus, we’re not sure.
They were probably all paid off, but some
would have also been concerned with the danger
posed by the Persian Empire growing uninhabited
in their vicinity.
Ultimately, the allies made little difference
for Croesus.
First, he and Cyrus fought to a stalemate
at the Battle of Pteria in 547 BC.
Afterwards, he was decisively defeated at
the Battle of Thymbra.
Croesus retreated to his capital of Sardis,
hoping to wait out the winter until his reinforcements
arrived.
Cyrus, however, followed him, laid siege on
Sardis and captured the capital after two
weeks.
Just like that, the Kingdom of Lydia had fallen
and was now part of the Achaemenid Empire.
The fate of Croesus himself, however, is more
of a mystery.
Ancient accounts are rather fanciful and claim
that the god Apollo came down from Olympus
and saved the king before his execution and,
consequently, Cyrus accepted him as an advisor.
Shockingly, modern historians don’t think
this actually happened, and many of them believe
that Croesus did, indeed, die in 546 BC, after
the fall of Sardis, either by his own hand
or by being burned on a pyre.
According to Herodotus, while on the pyre,
Croesus cried out the name of Solon three
times.
Only then did he truly understand what the
wise Athenian tried to teach him, that no
man is truly blessed until he dies well because,
until then, his fortune could change at any
time.